this is such distressing news I want you
to take us away from the headlines in
the obligatory of the TV video of
airplanes flying around what a military
people think about the idea our planes
are diverted because they're within 20
nautical miles of a Russian jet yeah and
Tom in addition we had our drones these
are big aircraft these Predator drones
they're 50 foot wingspan intercepted by
Russian aircraft so we've got a mix-up
between Russian fighters military US
drones now our planes on planes and at
the same time Russian missiles are
flying from the Caspian Sea a so Admiral
who decides who gets to fly and what
route and what direction absolutely
nobody controls the airspace this is the
wild okay I want to get in this vine of
your questions dead on you do ads the
military does ads between football games
to get kids to join the military they
always show the razzle-dazzle guy on the
boat he's 19 years old he's got the
headphones on and he's controlling big
important things yeah do we have a kid
in the Mediterranean controlling the air
space that we're in and the Russians
have somebody in the Caspian Sea doing
the same thing and are they talking to
each other yes to all except are they
talking to each other they are not
talking to each other the Russians also
have controllers in Lebanon and on ships
in the Mediterranean on a ship right
next to that US ship where the control
is going from it's a huge fur ball there
is no control right now as lot of air
Putin playing two sides he absolutely is
and you know kind of what's going on we
see Vladimir Putin all the time taking
off his shirt this is kind of the
equivalent of that he's launching
missiles he's got aircraft going he's
got tanks moving it he says he wants to
coordinate plans with the US and then he
also says he's attacking rebels but he's
also propping up Assad how can I that
all be true it's disingenuous what he's
doing vaani is supporting Assad the same
way he's supporting the rebels in
Ukraine when he says he's going after
the Islamic state I don't think anybody
seriously believes what will be our
response and we have so much to
talk about in this hour with you about
these events how do we respond to this
ash Carter or Secretary of Defense
tragically flawed was his phrase
yesterday we've got to prioritize I
think we need to go after the Islamic
state hi hard militates on the ground I
think so not a hundred fifty thousand
but we probably need ten thousand to
fifteen thousand to do the Special
Forces do the forward air control and
really push this should I put some of
those troops in Damascus let's review
the map east of Israel is Damascus we
sort of know it from Lawrence of Arabia
north of there is where Assads from on
the coast as where the Russian troops
are and then the Islamic state is
distant to the east where do you put our
boots on the ground in this will sound
somewhat odd to you but not in Syria at
this point they should be in Iraq
because this from a u.s. perspective is
initially going to be a bombing campaign
ultimately our Special Forces will need
to go into Syria but not certainly into
demanding the most important article
today Patrick Lions buried in the New
York Times a 11 Russia puts new weapon
into play they send a cruise missile 900
miles this isn't the Falkland Wars this
is not an Exocet missile is it not at
all this isn't a missile that we have
used many times you've heard of it it's
the Tomahawk missile sometimes we
jokingly refer to the Russian variant as
the Tomahawks key and it is a very
capable weapon as we've seen it goes
about 900 miles our missile goes about
1,500 miles are probably has better
accuracy but this is a very capable
weapon and launched from the Caspian Sea
and nine other sales 900 miles to get
the map out strove inna says this catch
into his brain was NATO's priority here
NATO has to support its NATO ally in the
region which is Turkey and you're seeing
a meeting this week in Brussels of all
the defence ministers including ash
Carter one thing on the table will be
how do we support Turkey we will have so
much honest to the hour how is this link
to Ukraine that seems to be the other
themes yeah in a strange way what Putin
is playing here is trying to convince
the West that he wants to be part of
taking on the Islamic state he'll then
go to the
Europeans and say look I'm playing
nicely with you against the Islamic
state can we now lift the sanctions in
Ukraine it's a strategy that won't work
because it's transparently false